hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to mr. hops Playhouse a
house of horrors a house of terror a
house of devious toys imagine that
you're back in your childhood Oh such a
sweet baby whatever your name is oh so
adorable but among your many toys of
which you have a plethora of one toy
stands out mr. Hobbes he just gives you
the critter he just gives you the creeps
for one reason or another I gotta say
that's that's really well done that's
terrifying anyway so that is the premise
for this game hah 'was move jump run
pick up e-z just like this game's gonna
be when I'm done with it
dad can you take mr. hop tonight he
scares me why
don't be silly Ruby what would Nana
think of you saying that she made him
just for you no come on I'll leave your
nightlight on try to get some sleep
smooches that's not good that's that
good that's what you call not good oh
that's creepy dude
mom I hate it I hate it why do I hate it
why do I hate this I hate this toys make
noise if only Rubin and listen to her
parent ID'd her toys away be sure to
jump over the toys scattered around the
house setting them off good to track
unwanted attention oh I see I see
ah I see okay just gonna stunt she's got
a curb stomp on this bear real quick
okay we're good okay jump over to baby
don't stomp on the baby
okay we're good we're good okay we're
good we're good we're fine it's all good
yo incus hmm footsteps can be deafening
make sure it's completely safe before
coming out of hiding okay whatever you
say where am I
what does that Poli what does that sound
use headphones and listen carefully to
your son I am using headphones Oh what
was the other way was there stuff to get
wait there was something back there that
maybe I shouldn't run didn't mean it I
did not mean it there was something here
okay what does it mean visible what does
it mean visible what does visible mean I
don't I don't know it visible means hi
that's what visible means it means your
big eyeballs can see me oh oh god oh god
why did I come here I came here
standstill to regain your stamina okay
great there was no point to go down that
room that room was a useless room why I
hate my parents Modern Art
okay it's real hard to jump over those
things you don't go any farther for
sprinting I just gotta say that you
don't go any farther oh crap this this
must be a bad dream make your way back
to bed I don't know bad maybe that's
okay I can't go in there
alright cool I'm gonna go away now
everything's good everything's fine
everything's totally good totally fun
all good yeah think I can't go that way
bro for the best I should probably back
to bed is these real tight jumps here I
didn't mean it
oh my god mister hop okay leave whoa
whoa
mr. hoppity whoo buddy
[Music]
mr. hoppity hippity hoppity what about
parents from is this door open now or uh
maybe okay it's still locked I don't
know why oh damn this game press down oh
I'm a ducking okay running is a bad idea
running is just a bad idea in general
running just bad bad idea
running is just bad 100 percent wait
wait wait what but but okay how about
that's how you do it that's how we're
gonna do it that's how we do it that's
how we do it we use the toys against him
that's it I'm a genius oh let's there's
no toys to use against him here [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh you do run you do jump farther
if you run you do aah
hey what it towards me boss oh [ __ ] okay
I am just bad at this game but I'm gonna
get good everybody just buckle the
buckle up and we're gonna be fine
[Music]
nothing here bud
okay nothing here bud nothing here bud
in ski
maybe there's my chance oh yeah it's my
chances I choose who I am the best that
ever existed oh bomb find the Rubies
mother well I think it's a lost cause I
think at this point there's a lost cause
I should just cry out climb through the
window okay this is impossible
oh yeah it's impossible what that clown
come from where did this come from wait
what is this all out hello anniversary
eighteenth okay Oh everything about this
is horrible
[Music]
fine as far as far as one can oh I get
it
some [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] look
some doors need a key
that means there's a key somewhere in
here right right
there must be right or somewhere there's
a key somewhere aha
here's the key knock to the front door
but I bet to the other room door oh wait
what was that what the hell I see oh oh
[ __ ] me okay we're fine
oh okay I didn't realize that it was
that way okay so and here maybe this
door this key yeah I regret oh I regret
oh I regret I regret it's fine it's fine
it's fine everything's fine DEP recorder
a sticky note attached reads under the
mirror
understood big papa understood big geez
you got it buds you got it okay I'm out
of here
thank you under the mirror where's the
mirror under the mirror here's a mirror
okay I guess not this mirror what's here
what is this says there's something says
there's something here I don't know what
that would be there's something here but
it doesn't say what probably something
to do with the tape recorder some crap
like that oh okay under the mirror okay
wait wait wait that's odd
I saw [ __ ] that's bad SEP Tara 8th Jenna
Ruby and I went to see Esther yesterday
Ruby always loved seeing her grandmother
Nana as she calls her she's not been
doing so well in recent months we went
round the other weekend and she was just
staring at the wall we had to really
shake her to snap her out of it and then
she was just fine and like nothing had
happened
God knows how long she'd been doing that
for we've booked her in for a doctor's
appointment I'm supposed to be recording
ideas for a new novel ha ha ha ha okay
so fine Tim why do i why is this my job
why is this my job Oh mr. hops you're
different wait mr. hops some happen to
you I don't know if I like it but so I'm
happy to mr. hops okay I'm mr. ups every
time every time every time every time
every time every time is so scary so
scary excuse me I need a sippy of water
to deal with your crap really sucking
from the teeth of that water bottle yeah
yeah oh okay it's fine it's fine it's
fine it's fine it's fine it's fine
youie there's no tape over here are you
joking me
are you joking me no oh I don't like it
Oh what are you doing you you you were
just being the sassiest of Sue's right
now I can't deal I cannot deal okay so
I'm starting to get a hang of it
yeah I'm not I'm not I get it I'm not I
get it I'm not here we go with another
table September 14th
Jenna and I stopped to see Esther again
today the place was filthy I'm not sure
how it could have gotten so bad so
quickly Esther doesn't seem to be
keeping herself clean either and it's
almost like she didn't recognize us
her appointment is tomorrow Jenna is
worried she might have to go into care
I'll keep this documented I hope Ruby
doesn't have to see her like this okay
cool that's great
oh that's real good poor Nana making
dolls and stuff so I'm just guessing
that these tapes are gonna spawn in in
random places whoo which means it could
be in here now this is a distinct
possibility that they could be in here
or did I just go in the same stupid
plate I just win the same dumb goddamn
place again because I'm an idiot
weird huh ah well whoo whoo whoo
Hey look in here there's a lot of
goodies hey what about this door nope
okay good I don't know why that would
would be locked where's another goddamn
- Moo's oh hey you
Oh Oh says something's right there I
don't know what that means though oh
come on oh come on okay huh Oh a
September 15th as of recording this
Esther's in the hospital her neighbors
called the police in the early hours of
the morning because they could hear her
screaming she will be there for a few
days we've told Ruby that she had a fall
and that she's okay we're waiting on a
diagnosis okay good great good great
good great Oh mr. Hobbs are you doing
you did good I didn't do anything
I you know I'm just the worst I'm the
worst at everything okay how about in
here now oh [ __ ] oh God pushing my luck
here there's nothing wait what wait whoa
whoa go oh I regret I regret everything
I regret everything I regret everything
I've ever do hate you I hate you I hate
you I hate all of you why did I go I why
did I go in here this is a bad idea I
went in again why I'm not honest I'm
sure hi how you doing can I talk to you
boy boy bullying okay goodbye
I'll see you around thank you for the
wonderful time weird interdimensional
portal
oh wow wow wow wow whoa whoa I gotta be
back here what the heck oh what the
frequency what K hey hey wait you're
supposed to go to the toy
not to me you sillies Wow didn't know
you could see me that good no didn't
know you don't have high so I assumed
that you know your eyes went into the
interdimensional portal and you know
I've might have been safe from your
right listen buddy oh that was a
meandering stroll okay I'm just gonna
assume that it's nothing's ever gonna be
in there ever in the history of forever
there will be nothing in there ever
unless it need to go back in there and
trigger the eyes I probably do okay I
need to go back and I need to get eyes
okay here we go okay so you're a serious
news you lose now I'm trying to be
really careful because I know that if I
die get reset back to a pretty far back
please
I just gotta find these goddamn tapes
come on please mr. Hobbs cooperate with
me mr. helps I need you to cooperate
with me mr. ops mr. Hobbs
mr. hops I need you to cooperate with me
mr. Hobbs
God you suck
what the hell is happening I'm getting
murdered by RNG here do you really
expect me to thread this needle like
this there he goes finally Jesus it must
just be completely random his movements
okay where's this tape where's the tape
where's the time need tape need tape hey
okay must be in the kitchen right that's
the only other place it could be there a
god damn you September 17th we took Ruby
to the hospital to see her Nana Esther
made a soft toy for her called mister
hop a small rabbit Esther always knitted
her closing toys Ruby was thankful but I
must admit this toy does not have a good
look to it something quite unsettling
does have a look to it yeah yeah yeah
you know it's a little a little weird
yeah little weird okay I'm gonna check
down here just in case you never know
and now I got a backtrack through the
whole goddamn place Oh God so I got
fired forever right Lily Lily other
floats will flail oh oh
oh now he's got a professional shocked
expression on his face whoo I'll try
this technique [ __ ] technique - Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
technique - smart okay here we go yeah
oh ha ha ha gotcha
that's [ __ ] that's your [ __ ] ha ha
I've got the technique now that I've got
the technique down you'll never beat me
I'm unbeatable
I know how to bait you I'm a masturbator
all right it's gotta be here right it's
gotta be where else would it be
right right where else would it be there
it is finally September 19th we just had
a call Esther passed away in her sleep
the doctors couldn't give us a diagnosis
and even said this sudden passing his
bizarre we will have to tell Ruby when
she gets home from school this isn't
gonna be easy on any of us yeah whoa
Nana looked into the fires of hell and
she saw me oh my god
oh [ __ ] I'm just a scared little girl
I'm just a wee baby I'm just do we baby
when I wear with the last one B just to
cover my bases I gotta go back to the
bedroom you never know with these things
you never know I never know anyway okay
definitely not here can I just go back
to sleep and everything's gonna be just
fine
Nana isn't a possessed demon making two
possessed demon toys okay so it's gotta
be over this friend which would make
sense or its back towards the end cuz
it's the last one I gotta get make sense
maybe it's in the parents bed tea blah
I have a new nightmare now have a new
nightmare I have a new nightmare it's
the parents boudoir September 22nd Ruby
says that mr. hops toy creeps her out
but it's the only thing that she has to
remember her grandmother by I keep
hearing bumps tonight like somebody's
walking around and scaring Jenna and I I
keep a handgun in the safe but I'm
considering keeping it closer to me we
locked that room so the Ruby can't get
into it Jenna keeps the key under the
house plan in the hallway I think which
hallway a lot of hallways quite a few
actually there's a lot of hallways this
all right there's a lot of houseplants
Oh No okay let me cover this way first
because we're closer to it we're going
easy-peasy
there's something in that couch cushion
that it is there's something in there
there's something easy ZZZ okay there's
no house plants in here so it's gotta be
to the left
oh I mean it what was I doing what did I
just what am i I'm an idiot I don't know
what's wrong with me I just a [ __ ]
waltzed into that my house plant do you
mean the Christmas tree here we go ha
hip it up hip hop hippity hop bunny who
maybe haven't you wait I wonder if
something's changed in here again let's
see what happens easy easy easy so easy
so easy nothing oh nothing nothing what
bad yeah nothing okay there's nothing
there was no point in coming here there
was absolutely no point I've really
ruined everything about everything okay
all right I'm fine everything's good
we're gonna go get a gun we're gonna
shoot mr. hops in his big stupid face
okay good good let's go okay whoops
sorry didn't mean to tell you about that
mr. hops a going to get a girl
let's go get a gun yeah give us a gun
okay April 1804 1/8
I bet I bet I bet wasn't in April it's
in the UK it's it's backwards they do
things the other way I'm gonna go get
you this is a bad idea this is a bad
idea kid that kid this just bad it is
bad this bad ideas about your mr. Romm
will you let me you Hobbs
will you go boomba jobs and uh make your
houses meet you up do you go get there's
something very wrong about this I have a
bad wit I got a bad feeling wait I got a
bad feeling I got one of those bad this
something's not right here wait a minute
everybody I got a lot of red flags going
up every which way I a lot of red flags
here I feel something and feeling just
like a little yeah I got a bad feeling
about dude probably in the basement I
bet in the basement ho ho Bob
chip come on mother
Oh left mouse button or why to shoot
right of course
Thanks Oh bang right in the dick
[Music]
take that mr. hops
take that take that mr. Hobbs that'll
show you mr. hops like that's not right
guys guys something's not right
Ruby come give your nan all back gasps
no okay
all right I got a kiss for you now I
can't shoot I was gonna shoot her right
now we're in the nog Oh God
Nana but I thought you were oh wow Ruben
hey roomie how do out of my video hey
whoa I will not
oh oh I see okay I get it I get it I get
it I get it I get it I get it I get it I
get it
I get it how a boost wait a man all
right all right but boy foot foot foot
but but but wait do now I know I got it
I got it I got I got I got I got smart
I'm smart I'm smart I'm smart I'm smart
watch this watch this ha oh wait no cats
not necessarily the correct answer I
think I'm supposed to be able to shoot I
think something's bugged I think
something's bogged guys oh no oh come on
you can't do this to me maybe this maybe
I can restart it Nana okay do I still
have my shoe tease in Quebec Ruby come
give your Nana big yes okay Nana Nana
but I thought you were
No okay I can shoot now okay aha
si si si ha yeah this is what was
supposed to happen this was supposed to
go okay okay got it nailed it I'm the
best hi
armed police drop the gun now oh no it's
kind of just a kid oh god oh god oh oh
no oh that's not good
that's what you call not good ending
escape art wait what are their what that
was amazing by the way
by the way miss Roth's Playhouse that
was really well done what other stuff do
you have moon bit studios what do you
have nothing nothing nothing nothing Wow
it just started this amazing did you
start this is well done that's really
good this was really well made yeah this
was really really really well made I
love this I love this this was awesome
this was really really well done
I am super impressed by this it kept it
interesting even after I kind of like
got through the mechanics of mr. hops
patrolling the area by keeping it fresh
with little jump scares here and there
it was had a very creepy thing the
mechanic was good it kept me on my toes
it didn't stay over States welcome that
music was great that ambience was great
everything about it was great it was
really well done and mr. ops is very
scary thank you everybody so much for
watching hope you enjoyed mr. hops
Playhouse here if you did maybe
considering supporting moon bit studios
like they for me I think the same was
Jake it's done a really good job here a
really really nice job taking the retro
style and making it scary so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to see other scary games that I've
played there is a playlist in the
description
and probably over there where you can
check out hundreds and hundreds of scary
games that I have played thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know he thought down in the comments
below and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]